Put on your 3D glasses now
🎶Skrattar Du Förlorar Duuuuuuuuuuuuuuu🎶
MANEEEEEEEEEN
Welcome to You Laugh You Lose (again?)
If you skratta du förlora (of course)
Youtube's favorite show of all time (are you sure about that?)
I don't have any issues uploading this at all. Which version are you watching?
Version one? Perhaps version two or maybe even version ei-eight
God ***
2018 Youtube sucks. I can't even say the F word anymore. All the dank stuff. All the good stuff. I have cut out.
*Felix being sad*
Anyway, let's enjoy the show if you laugh you lose, but you can't do both when you can't do either.
Skrattar Du Förlorar Du. Let's begin a challenge. Let's go. (Sexy wink)
Oh. It's good old Skyrim. Wow, that looks a bit strange
Me too ... great
I like how the bear and him are confused...
Oh he's back..
Yes, yes, I am feeling all right, how are you doing Louis Le-Letrust?
Trush. Can't read.
Wow what a great clip to start off with. What else are we gonna skratta?
Talking action figures my idea. Love it. Let's see what I say.
𝐘𝐨𝐮 𝐞𝐚𝐭 𝐚𝐥𝐥 𝐦𝐲 𝐛𝐞𝐚𝐧𝐬
(Christian Channel)
*laughs* God *** it.
Can we blur the the word?
*laughs*
WhAt Do I sAy?
(Beware Headphone Users)
(Screams of eternal suffering)
It goes on for a minute
*Pewds joins the eternal suffering*
No, thank you. Not skratta.
The rule is simple.
Loud does not equal funny.
Trust me. I know I've been unfunny for years
(Excellent self-awareness)
All right moving on
Hey!
that's-...
What is wrong with them?
Can you do this? BUT CAN YOU DO THIS??
*claps*
BUT CAN YOU DO THIS? BUT CAN YOU DO THIS? BUT CAN YOU DO THIS? BUT CAN YOU DO THIS? BUT CAN YOU DO THIS? BUT CAN YOU DO THIS? BUT CAN YOU DO THIS? BUT CAN YOU DO THIS? BUT CAN YOU DO THIS? BUT CAN YOU DO THIS? BUT CAN YOU DO THIS?
I don't know what I just witnessed.
But *uhhh* it was beautiful. That was very nice.
No... no...
That has to be fake ..., I mean ... that looks pretty fake to be honest.
*laughs*
I want to do that on Edgar now.
Yeah, no, that's definitely fake.
FAKE!
Marlin: Dory says a lot of things in her sleep, ok.
Dory: I put a whole bag of jellybeans up my ***.
Great that's that's great. You know whatever you want to do to be happy.
(epic music )
That was nicely timed.
*Quack... ala ... quack ... ala..*
*BOOM*
*WEEZY*
*WEEEEEZY*
Goddammit
*💥💥💥*
Well done. It's the short one that always get me man.
[Dragon Ball Z fighting sound and music]
Jesus Christ!
[Dragon Ball Z fighting sound and music continues]
It's a beautful edit. *yes, it is*
[Dragon Ball Z fighting sound and music still going on] *laughs*
Oh wow!
Fantastic!
Top 10 Anime Battles of 2018 EVERYONE!
*SNSD's Gee plays*
Oh.
Ooh. Kay.
Uh. *laughs*
YEEEES! *birb memes everybody*
YEEEEEEEEEEEESSSSSSSS *laughs*
*WEEZY*
What the f- was that?
Ohhhhhh. [Lord of the Rings music.. ]
The crabs. They have learned to walk forward, in a straight line.
My God, we're doomed!
My favorite one is still the one with the cakes, but that was pretty good.
"You think what I'm thinking for? Aim for the bushes."
Oh not this clip. :((((
♪ There goes my hero, watch him as he goes ♪
And we're gonna end it there. :(((
We don't need to see more.
And it was a nice little clip that we all enjoyed.
And nothing bad ever happens, cause nothing ever happens.
And bad happens are bad and not skratta-worthy.
OK? You dont skratta at bad.
*distorded annoying music*
I think this would've been funny if we would didn't give my ears completely.
*You wanna see my power level huh?*
[super Saiyan sound]
*YOU LIKE JAZZ*
*laughs*
*Machine gun laughter*
*But I can go beyond this*
There's more?
AAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAAHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHHH
*Y O U   L I K E   S M O O T H   J A Z Z*
*laughs*
That's good.
I do like smooth jazz to be honest.
I'm a big fan of smooth jazz.
*Predator plays Axel F*
*Predator continues playing Axel F*
I love the movie edit. They're so good. Goddammit.
"It's working! It's wo-"
*WEEZ*
*WEEEZ*
The movie edits are the best.
They're just the best.
Oh yeeeeeeeees!
Well I think it's time to end this episode here. Did you skratta or did you förlora?
Let me know in the comments down below.
In case you didn't know where the comments were. That's where they are there.
Leave a something and remember to always brush your teeth.
(when you have to improvise to get to 10min )
BUT CAN YOU DO THIS?